[Music]
today's question comes from sean in
missouri i'm currently in baby step two
and i will be completely debt free next
year i have a career but i'm not sure if
it's my calling is it a bad idea while
i'm in baby step two to pay for a
one-time coaching session with a career
counselor to get some career goals and
get some guidance on how to reach those
goals i can budget in the expense and
pay for it with cash on hand so i
wouldn't incur additional debt
that's not a bad idea uh that is a
very inexpensive in the grand scheme of
things if you're in control of that
budget and you cash flow for one session
that's not going to cost you too much i
would do my homework though and make
sure that it's a reputable coach
but i'd like to save you the money on
the coaching session and uh for thirty
dollars you can get that get clear
career assessment at ramseysolutions.com
and uh get your results and then call
the ken coleman show give me five
minutes and then we can decide on a
career coach
and i think even then uh that is a good
decision to get some clarity from
somebody else and so that we begin to
say all right now i can begin to see the
mountaintop and i can figure out how to
climb up the mountaintop so you can
definitely cash flow that good idea
oz guinness years ago did a uh
a talk a book called the calling yes
and um man i guess that was probably 25
years ago i read that book something
like that
but um
i've noticed in my life that uh
the first thing i started doing was
earning money to eat yes
and uh so get the wolf away from the
door pay the bills that kind of stuff
took a job yes the second thing i did
was i moved from that into a career yes
with meaning
and um and and i'm talking about the
stuff i do today it start it didn't it
didn't start all altruistic i didn't
start with
a clear understanding that this was the
calling on my life
uh now i can look back 30 years later
and say of working in the same thing and
say this was a call yep it's god's call
on my life and i'm sure of that and
those of you that have
benefited by the things we do around
here are sure of that
and so uh but it but when i started
uh you know and i get in front of the
microphone the first time write the
first book um
i was still in career mode at that point
i was beyond job i was i was trying to
do something with meaning and so forth
but i was not
i would not have been prepared
truthfully yes
to say that's a calling i had to realize
that a little bit later yeah and and you
know what i'm glad you actually brought
this up i'm not sure when you're 21 and
you're in college you know what your
calling is no
but i would say if we redefine calling
for just a moment and say calling
is to be who you were created to be now
once you find out the answer to that you
can make a great career out of that and
that's what we teach but calling if we
really look at it we say what what is
calling that's how we at ramsey
solutions look at work when we say works
on a four-letter word folks we're trying
to challenge you to say you were created
to work created to contribute
and so calling is realizing that there's
something that i was created to do
because i've got talent it turns out
there's things i love to do and turns
out there's results that really
fire my heart up so calling is actually
being who you're supposed to be career
multiple ways to fulfill calling
now i suppose the
the phrase evolved from
uh from people of faith or
or a pastor would say god called me
to preach
and um
you know our good friend rabbi lapin a
jewish orthodox rabbi um says that the
word worship and the word work
are very similar words in hebrew that
did that in a very real sense that when
you're working you're workshipping
that's exactly what it is and that's why
we have
uh worship service on the weekend and
customer service
on monday you know and so that that's a
there's a lot of overlap there and so
calling is saying
you know it's a throwback whether you
whether you're a person of faith or not
you're accidentally throwing back to
people of faith
and saying okay god's calling me
his calling on my life is this which is
what you're saying is what you're
designed to do that's it that's it so
you are
you we are all called to contribute if
i'm going to say that i mean at the end
of the day that's what god wants for us
is to just be us because we all got
something unique to contribute